Neutron stars, other densities,
things that are not black holes in there cause we might find the most dangerous
substance in existence. Strange matter, a bizarre thing.
So extreme that it bends the rules of the universe and could infect and destroy
everything it comes into contact with.
Or it could teach us about how the universe began. Maybe both.
To understand how extreme strange matter already is,
we first need to get a few basics.
What is a neutron star and how does strange matter break the rules of the
universe? To get all of this into one video,
we'll grossly over simplify a few things,
but we'll provide you with further reading if you want more details.
The neutron star is what remains after a very massive star explodes in a
Supernova. When this happens,
the stars core collapses under its own gravity with such a strong Inwood force
that it squeezes nuclei and particles together violently electrons are pushed
into protons, so they merge and turn into neutrons.
All the nothing inside of atoms is suddenly completely filled with particles
that really don't want to be close to each other but have no choice.
They desperately pushed back against gravity against the collapse.
If gravity wins, they will become a black hole. If they win,
they become a neutron star.
This makes neutron stars like giant atomic nuclei the size of a city,
but holding the mass of our sun and here things get weird.
The environment in the core of neutron stars is so extreme that the rules of
nuclear physics change and this could lead to a strange and extremely dangerous
substance, but let's not get ahead of ourselves.
We first need to know the rules before we learn how they can be broken.
Protons and neutrons,
the particles making up the nuclei of atoms are made up of smaller particles
called quarks. Quarks really don't want to be alone.
They are what we call confined. You can try to separate them,
but the harder you pull, the harder they try to pull themselves back together.
If you use a lot of energy, they just use this energy to create new quarks.
Quarks only exist together as the building blocks of other particles and have
never been observed by themselves.
They come in many types but only to appear to make stable matter.
The up and down quarks found in protons and neutrons.
All other quarks seem to decay away quickly,
but this may be different inside neutron stars.
The forces operating in their cause are so extreme that they are actually
similar to the universe that shortly after the big bang neutron star cores are
like fossils which can let us peer back in time to the beginning. Everything.
So learning how quarks behave inside a neutron star is a way of understanding
the very nature of the universe itself.
One hypothesis is that inside a neutron star,
call protons and neutrons d confinement,
all the particles cram shoulder to shoulder dissolve and melt into a sort of
Barth of quarks.
Uncountable numbers of particles become one giant thing made purely from quarks.
Quark matter, a star made from this is called a quark star.
Though from the outside it may not look any different than a regular neutron
star. Now we can finally talk about the most dangerous substance.
If the pressure and cited quark star is great enough,
it may get stranger literally in the cause of neutron stars.
Some of the quarks may be converted into strange quarks.
Strange quarks have bizarre nuclear properties and they are heavier and for the
lack of a better word, stronger. If they turn up,
they could create strange matter.
Strange matter might be the ideal state of matter, perfectly dense,
perfectly stable,
indestructable more stable than any other matter in the universe,
so stable that it can exist outside neutron stars.
If this is the case, we have a problem, it might be infectious.
Every piece of matter at touches might be so impressed by its stability that it
would immediately turn it into a strange matter. Two,
protons and neutrons would dissolve and become part of the quark bath,
which frees energy and creates more strange matter.
The only way to get rid of it would be to throw it into a black hole,
but then again, who cares? All of it is inside neutron stars,
except when neutron stars collide with other neutron stars, all black holes,
they spew out tremendous amounts of their insights,
some of which could include little droplets of strange matter called strange
lifts. Strange lids are as dense as the core of a neutron star.
They could be really small, maybe even Subatomic,
but even the largest strangely, it's wouldn't be any bigger than a rocket.
These strange lifts would drift through the galaxy for millions or billions of
years until they meet a star or planet. By chance,
if one were to strike earth,
it would immediately start converting it into strange matter.
The more it converts, the more it would grow. Ultimately,
all of the atoms making up earth would be converted.
Earth would become a hot clump of strange matter the size of an astroid.
If a strange lit strikes the sun,
it would collapse into a strange style eating through it like fire through a dry
forest. This would not change the sun's mass mage,
but it will become way less bright.
So earth would freeze to death and like a tiny virus,
we'd have no way to see a strangely coming worse still some theories suggest
strange lifts are more than common outnumbering all stars in the galaxy.
The strange lids could have formed very early after the big bang when it was as
hot and dense as a neutron star core everywhere they might be clumping around.
The gravity of Ganache says as the universe expanded and evolved,
strange Litz could even be so new rose and massive that they might actually be
the dark matter we suspect holds galaxies together. But then again,
maybe not.
This is speculation and the earth and sun and planets haven't been consumed in a
wildfire of strange let's in the past few billion years.
So the odds seem good that it won't happen anytime soon.
[inaudible]
understanding these strange objects today,
maybe the key to understanding the birth of our universe and why it grew to look
the way it does now.
When scientists first started playing with magnets and wise and thinking about
electrons,
they had no idea how technology would evolve in the next hundred years.
The scientists thinking about the cause of neutron stars and strange matter
today may be setting up humans for a future beyond our wildest imaginations.
Oh, maybe not ton will tell.
So while you're waiting to see if the universe gets destroyed,
you might still want to find out more about it.
We've got our friends from brilliant can be your insight into a whole world of
signs,
black holes and all brilliant is a website that helps you tackle science in a
practical way with interactive problem solving courses and daily challenges in
maths, logic,
condensing snaring each problem gives you all the tools you need to crack
complex topics all by yourself.
It's learning by doing but with your brain instead of your hands.
Use your curiosity to get to the bottom of puzzles and courses about things like
classical mechanics, astronomy, gravitational physics, and much more.
If you click the link in the description or visit brilliant.org/nutshell you can
sign up for free and learn more things than you can imagine.
And there's an extra pack for quotes cause aren't viewers the first 688 people
to use the link, get 20% off that annual membership,
which lets you view all the daily problems in the archives and unlock every
cause. Brilliant helps you and your day a little smarter.
You might get hooked on the experience.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].